I'm Harley Quinn and I'm the Joker huh
now what was it about Harlequin and the
Joker that made you think yeah I'm going
to dress up with those guys today I just
love Harlequin I think it's just really
quirky she's really cute in a psychotic
kind of way but you just can't help but
love her and her costumes are awesome
what's not to love the Clown Prince of
Crime wonderful man wonderful dreams one
for the gadgets lots of death now guys
what is the best thing about the Joker
and Harlequin and what is the worst
thing about Batman worst thing about
Batman is that he tends to win quite a
lot I think it's just everything that's
the best about us well kind of yeah I
mean the Batman keeps ruining my fun
whereas we're awesome and she kind of
Abbes my every word which is good
because otherwise she'd get it so Joker
what would you do to Harlequin oh well I
didn't know there's so many toys to play
with but I don't think you'd walk for a
while or use your hands or face so
pretty much anything it'll be good
without of you Pookie now tell me a
little bit more about the Joker it's a
conference of climbers have already said
hi how's it going genius
fantastic joke teller fantastic at
parties provided you don't want to live
to the end of it and all-around fun guy
Joker what's your biggest trick that
you've done at a party biggest jerk I've
done to the party well I think my
favorite trick of the party I invited
all my friends round for dinner and and
then I guess the whole often we laughed
and they laughed and they laughed and
they laughed and then they stopped do
you think they'll be a day when you
finally get rid of the Batman it's
coming pretty soon and would you have
lots of other people involved in this
would there be Harlequin along and maybe
it a bit of Bane too or do you think
you're a bigger badass and all those
guys together well obviously I mean
Benny can hardly throw a punch and Holly
can come along if she promises not to
screw things up again what did you think
about cristiano land leaving you out of
this latest film were you bit miffed he
and I had artistic differences shall we
say he saw himself alive I saw him dead
he saw me dead I saw me very much alive
and the Batman very much dead but
apparently that's not how he wrote it in
the script
you